las ureña ciudad inglesa de bacild
Natalia parkomenco originaria de melito
Paul Ucrania es beneficiaria del
programa hogares para Ucrania Amanda
propietaria de la casa acogió a Natalia
como su hija
Ahora vivo aquí y estoy feliz de estar
aquí tengo suerte de haber encontrado a
una mujer realmente agradable
ella me ayuda ellas como mi mamá vivimos
juntas estamos felices de estar juntas
y decir que pasarán el futuro no sé
quiero creer que la guerra terminará y
puedo volver a Ucrania
[Música]
desde el comienzo de la invasión rusa
alrededor de 150.000 personas se han
refugiado en Reino Unido la mayoría
acuden a este programa de viviendas en
el que cada refugiado ucraniano debe
contar con un patrocinador que se
encargue el alojamiento durante seis
meses sin embargo no todos los
ucranianos cuentan con la misma suerte
de Natalia ella da Virginia oriunda de
kiev quiere estudiar arquitectura en
Londres pero no cuenta con un
patrocinador en la capital inglesa
deberá abandonar a sus anfitriones en
basildon y Buscar un alojamiento
enviado solicitudes para buscar
habitaciones desafortunadamente hay una
proporción muy pequeña de respuestas Por
lo general estos pisos comunales
pertenecen a gente joven y buscan a
alguien de edad similar Generalmente
menor de 30 años
ellada es una de los tantos refugiados
que quedarán sin techo en Reino Unido
luego de los seis meses iniciales el
gobierno está dando incentivos de 350
euros mensuales a los anfitriones para
que renueven seis meses más su
patrocinio